Good morning Hank, it's Tuesday.
My son Henry doesn't watch a lot of television,
although he does enjoy uncle Hank's space videos.
But I recently watched 12 of the most popular programs for toddlers
to understand what he might be watching
and Hank, because I remembered that you
were a big fan of the show Blue's Clues
when you were in college,
I come to you today with an introduction
to contemporary children's television.
So Hank, in general, watching children's television
is a dark and surreal descent into madness,
where the characters on the screen talk directly to you.
So for example at the end of every episode
of Dora the Explorer
she'll be like 'What was your favourite part?'
and I'll be like, 'Well the weirdest part was the part
where you and your pet jaguar went camping
with nothing, but a flashlight and some snacks.'
And then she'll say, 'I like that part too!'
and I'll be like, 'No, I didn't like it Dora, I thought it was weird.
You're a toddler, you should be inside.'
Also Hank, in the world of contemporary children's television
we've apparently abandoned child labor laws
like take for example, the Dora the Explorer spin off, Diego.
Diego's like a 4 year old, who's been inexplicably
promoted to some kind of park ranger
that allows him to go around the world
and save animals.
Apparently there are a lot of animals
in distress, because like Wonder Pets,
which is about an operatic gerbil,
he saves animals in need,
as do the kids on Little Einsteins,
a show about kids who fly around in a rocket
called 'Rocket.'
But of course Hank, there are also people in need,
specifically child actors, and for those child actors
we have Special Agent Oso -
an OSO-special agent panda, who travels
around the world helping child actors learn to do things
like tie their shoes.
Team Umizoomi is also in the child actor assistant business
but they specialize in Math,
which can be a little bit humiliating because
they'll be like, 'Hey, do you know what shape this is?'
and I'll be like, 'Mmm, octahedron?'
and they'll say, 'That's right! its a dodecahedron.'
And I will feel the shame.
Hank, there are also lots of shows about kids
who go into their backyards and have
really compelling hallucinations like- The Cat in the Hat
and the Backyardigans and Phineas and Ferb -
which, by the way, is the best television program
I have ever seen for children or adults.
In fact, not to brag, but I own a
Perry the Platypus Swindon Town Swoodilypoopers doll.
It airs on the Disney channel, which also
contains Mickey Mouse Clubhouse.
The first time I saw Mickey Mouse Clubhouse
I was like, 'This is amazing, this is a television program
with no advertisements,' and then I realised the television program
IS the advertisement. What else?
Oh yeah, there's the hot slice of crazy known as 'Yo Gabba Gabba'.
Hank, I don't know what Yo Gabba Gabba is about
but, I do know that it contains more good music than MTV.
Hank, if you want to hear the Shins or Weezer or Weird Al or Mos Def on TV,
you HAVE to watch Yo Gabba Gabba.
And then you have the wildly popular Ni Hao, Kai-Lan,
a show that I'm surprised right wing commentators
haven't gotten upset about, given how they felt about the Teletubbies.
I mean Ni Hao, Kai Lan basically teaches American children the importance of
Confucian filial piety, a smattering of Mandarin Chinese words, and the very dangerous lesson
that the best way to solve your problems is by collaborating with a tiger.
Whereas in America, we know that the best way to
solve our problems is by not collaborating at all.
And lastly Hank, there are currently 2 different shows on television about octopuses
who inexplicably do not need water to survive.
There's the charming Oswald, and the terrifying Octonauts.
So the Octonauts live at the bottom of the ocean
in some kind of pressurised contraption, and their leader appears to be this monocled
octopus and then sometimes to help animals in distress, they travel around in
this anglerfish, which is awesome, except that the anglerfish has a male voice
and we all know that is a female anglerfish, because
if it were a male, it would be just a sperm-producing parasite on her side.
More importantly Hank, what's up with the octopus symbol that's on their hats
and their uniforms, and their coffee mugs?
Has their monocle octopus cohort created some kind of cult of personality where they
worship him as dear leader, and why is there a children's television program
celebrating this weird, underwater cult?!
And Hank, that's not even to mention Bubble Guppies, a show in which little mermaids
and merdudes despite living underwater, are able to have campfires.
No wonder our science scores are so low.
So Hank, those are my conclusions from a week of watching children's TV.
Don't Forget To Be Awesome
and I will see you on Friday.